welcome back to las vegas now millions
of people live
every day with severe pain it doesn't
matter if you start hurting today or if
you're dealing with an injury from 30
years ago
dr devin at spinal care of nevada and
his
gentle method of chiropractic care can
help
when my back gets out of alignment it
pinches nerves
and nerve pain is pretty awful you
are just mentally exhausted from
this pain that just seems to go
like this all day long
and at times i cry sometimes it's a
lifetime of wear and tear we have old
accidents false injuries we think
nothing about
what they catch up to us down the road i
came in and i was literally hobbling in
the door
you know i was bent over i couldn't even
stand up straight my wife faye
of all it's been probably now eight
months ago
she started developing tiredness fatigue
she had headaches she had nausea started
getting some adjustments
and probably after about three four
weeks she started feeling a little bit
better
noticeably so and in about two months
magically so to speak she was fine
danuka chiropractic
is a more gentle style of chiropractic
the the gentle approach avoids the the
twisting the cracking
or the manipulation um and our patients
just prefer that
we can treat a wide range of patients uh
young children
people who've been in bad car accidents
bad falls maybe we've even had surgery
before
up to 80 90 year old men and women with
severe osteoporosis and arthritis so
really one of the keys to our success
is our two day work up day one we're
going to sit down
and i'm going to listen to our patients
and i mean truly listen we'll run a
series of tests checking
every range of motion of their spine
orthopedic neurological test
posture and then we're going to take
digital
opposing view x-rays these are some of
the best type of films in our field
i'm going to study those i'm going to
study the notes so day two
we're going to sit down and i'm going to
go over the findings and listen if i
can't help someone
i'm going to let them know and i'm going
to get them to the right doc if i can
help i'm very straightforward
how long is it going to take what's it
going to cost what's my insurance do or
not do
because if you're anything like me you
don't want financial surprises and we're
going to get to work
and start getting some relief as soon as
possible my life's changed immensely
i'm pain-free where i used to have
shoulder
neck pain i wasn't able to lift my arms
brush my own hair it's almost like a
relief when he adjusts i can feel it
like that it's it's it's amazing
normally that two day work up
is 180 what we're going to do for
viewers of the show
is give it to the first 20 callers i
have to limit it
after that it goes up to regular price
for only 37
you heard dr devin that's a great deal
the first twenty callers will
only pay thirty seven dollars for both
normally
it's one hundred and eighty dollars call
702
566 hope or 46.73
you can get more info at drdevin.com